اعلان ترامب على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تروس سوشل بانه سيتم اعتقاله الثلاثاء
ومطالبته لانصاره بالتظاهر دعما له فجر
قنبله سياسيه في الاوساط الامريكيه تصريح
ترامب اعاد الى الاذهان مشهد السادس من
يناير واقتحام مبنى الكابيتال الامر الذي
استدعى استنفارا امنيا وقضائيا فالمسؤولون
في نيويورك ناقشوا الترتيبات الامنيه في
محكمه منهاتنا الجنائيه في حاله صدور
لائحه اتهام هذا المبدا
ولكن ما يمكن ان يحصل في حال ان حصل
الادعاء واريد ان اوضح هنا ان الادعاء يجب
ان يصول المحلفين واذا كان هناك تصويت
فباغلبيه
[موسيقى]
يعني اتهام ترامب
رسميا يستطيع الرئيس ترامب ان يذهب بنفسه
الى المركز الشرطه وطبعا
يسلم نفسه
تصريحات ترامب قبلت على الفور بالمواقف
السياسيه الداعمه حتى اللحظه ففي الوقت
الذي اعتبر رئيس مجلس النواب كيف قرار
اعتقالي ترامب ليس سوى اساءه استخدام
شنيعه للسلطه من قبل مكتب المدعي العام
سارع احد ابرز المنظمين لليله الكابيتال
علي الكسندر لتاييد ترامب والاعلان عن
استعداده لتنظيم مسيرات ترفض قرار المدعي
العام بحال صدوره
تواكب على الارض دائما ولكن ليس لهم دور
اساسي في هذا الموضوع الشرطه في نيويورك
لها الدور الاساسي وبداوا يتحضرون باي
محاولات شغب او لتظاهرات كبيره قد تؤدي
لاعمل
[تصفيق]
من المحتمل ان يجمع اعتقال ترامب اذا تم
الخطوات الروتينيه التي يواجهها كل متهم
من اخذ البصمات والتصوير مع كل الخصائص
الممنوحه لرئيس سابق كما يرافق جهاز
الخدمه السريه الامريكيه كل تحركاته
اخبر اعتقال ترامب افضل هديه يمكن ان
يتلقاها المرشح الاول للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله لان القنبله الموقوته تبقى في
دعوه
الامر الذي سيشكل نقطه نقاشات حاده في
الايام المقبله للتسليمان العربيه واشنطن